women are now less and less are getting
married less and less having children
before the age of 30. why do you think
that is women are delusional we think
we're hotter than we are women tend to
want traditional men men tend to want
traditional women but like how many
women like have a cookbook know how to
cook from scratch how many women would
delete their Instagram because their
husband told them to or even delete
certain photographs the men are looked
at as dogs if they cheat but the women
are not looked at as dogs if they have a
provocative picture on their Instagram
and if anything they'll die trying to
defend it and the men are shamed for it
they're called controlling and I'm just
like for not wanting your tits on
Instagram like get out of here
the true Geordie podcast